all right on Tuesday I at the end of the
class got on the subject of divination
which is a subcategory of a larger
subject which is whether one believes in
an unseen world or in beings that exists
in in a non perceivable fashion when I
have asked students in my CC or lit hum
courses about this the first thing they
say was does that include ghosts because
you can see it goes sometimes but in
general most students at Columbia don't
appear to believe in beings in an unseen
world you can't think about the ancient
world
with that in mind you have to go on a
consumption that everyone in the period
that we're talking about in these early
chapters that everyone believed that
there was an unseen world that there
were beings they could not perceive or
could perceive only in extraordinary
circumstances if you believed there was
an unseen world you could populate it
with with beings who could be would look
like anything you want since you
couldn't see them so whether they were
centaurs or werewolves or ell beings
like that or whether they're angels or
Jim or demons it doesn't
a whole lot of difference because
conceptually they shared the quality
that you could see them but you could
then categorize them and say that this
body of unseen beings is malevolent this
group is benevolent and here's another
big group who really couldn't care less
about people they just hang out the
issue for people was can you you know if
you believe there are these unseen
beings and you ascribe to them
capacities to act can you get them to
help you can you prevent them from
screwing you up can you force them to do
something or if they're doing things
just on their own can you identify and
predict what they're doing and
there's a whole array of spiritual
technologies and I think technology is
the right term to use here of spiritual
technologies to achieve these sorts of
goals to sacrifice I've mentioned is one
where you initially believed that by
carrying out a certain ritual you will
cause something to happen you know the
gods or the spirits or something of this
sort when you read about Agamemnon
sacrifice of his daughter in the
earliest part of the Iliad you're
dealing with the idea that this
sacrifice will atone for a sin that
Agawam Agamemnon has committed and as a
result the wind will blow and the fleet
will be able to to reach Troy so you can
have a notion that by sacrificing you
can cause something happen then you can
have the notion that you can discover
what is going to happen by contacting
the unseen world divination is a
technology to achieve that where you
do something whether it is applying a
red-hot bronze poker to a turtle shell
causing it to crack or whether you
observe the flight of birds or whether
you analyze the entrails of sheep these
are all forms of divining and all have a
common purpose now the idea of that
science and technology are linked is not
a purely early modern idea in other
words if these are technologies was
there a science related to it and the
answer is is yes and this was a science
that was predicated upon observation of
nature and it's the science of the
relationship between the macrocosm and
the microcosm where you maintain that
things that happen at a certain speed
and in a certain repli'd repeating
pattern at the macro level particularly
the movements of heavenly bodies that
these are models or alternatively that
these are causing parallel activities to
take place at the micro level the notion
of of scaling you know
cause and effect is a very very
appealing one the the single most
important idea in that has to do with
this sort of thing for modern times is
is Newton's law of gravity here you have
something that applies to heavenly
bodies at the most that the largest
possible aggregation and it applies to
you know the Apple falling off the tree
and it's the same formula Newton who of
course was a an alchemist and the man
who believed very strongly in in the
secrets of nature that could be
uncovered
Newton really achieved the goal of the
ancient and saying is there something
that we can observed in the heavens that
applies to us on the ground it is
surprising that people religion did not
take to Newton more readily because he
was doing what what people had wanted at
a later point
Darwin does something similar he says
that there is something that takes place
at the level of entire families or taxon
of of animal and vegetable life and it
takes place at the level of of
inheritance from one to another and of
course once Mendel's laws of genetics
are added to it and even more when DNA
is added to it you end up with the
notion that that evolution as
interpreted today with the insights from
DNA analysis that evolution goes from
the the largest aggregates of
of living organisms down to the smallest
so while we have a tendency to to debunk
the the absorption of ancient thinkers
in the macrocosm thinking that it has
something to do with a microcosm we have
to recognize that we do the same thing
and that's some of the most important
ideas that we have are precisely things
that link the macrocosm and microcosm
and alternatively some of the ideas we
have the hardest time with for example
that there are six dimensions beyond
number four that are wrapped up in
entities that are so small they cannot
be perceived that doesn't seem very
likely even though it's mathematically
required by the people who who derive
these theories because it doesn't scale
up it's simply something that happens at
the subatomic level and we cannot
perceive it all we can do is model it
mathematically and affirm on that basis
that it exists so there's a particular
appeal to the notion of the macrocosm
and microcosm the abundant evidence
around the world that from say the 3rd
millennium BC onward if not earlier you
had people who were aware of the
regularities of the motion of heavenly
bodies and particularly the regularities
of of eclipses that they then manifest
that awareness in building what are now
thought of as earlier prehistoric
observational
devices Stonehenge being one of them
that you know that's the indication of
that the notion of a macrocosm was there
at a very very early point and there's
no reason to think of that that the idea
doesn't go back a good deal farther it's
the connection with a microcosm of
course that's the that is the puzzle do
the motions of the heavenly bodies
represent or mirror or predict things
that are happened or are going to happen
in your own personal life and out of
this theory you come up with the idea of
the horoscope where if you can identify
the positions of heavenly bodies the
time you were born or at certain crucial
points you can predict what will happen
in your in your lifetime I've already
mentioned as somewhat later point and
more arcane one which is numerology
where numbers are seen as indicators
because you can have numbers that are on
a macro scale for example the number of
celestial spheres and numbers that are
on a micro scale such as you know which
day of the week is sacred something of
that sort but numerology develops temps
develop somewhat later than other types
of of divination the divination is
pretty much ubiquitous as mentioned
before than every society that where we
have the evidence sufficient evidence
seems to have some sort of divination
but if you take sacrifice witches
everywhere where you're in a sense
coercing the unseen world in a to do
something or to stop doing something
if the unseen world is you know beating
you with a stick you know the sacrifice
is a way to get it to stop so that's one
technology divination is another
technology but there's a third that has
to do with inspiration inspiration is
literally having a spirit inside you and
you can say well that's only etymology
but the fact the matter is that for the
period that we are dealing with in this
chapter and the next chapter two or
three inspiration literally means having
a spirit inside you and being informed
by or guided by that spirit at a you
know at one level this is a matter of
certain individuals who
who can prophesy because of of an
inspiration for the Greeks the Oracle at
Delphi was so important that you had
rulers and states that would base their
policies on what the Oracle said or what
they thought the Oracle said since the
Oracle was service specialists in
ambiguity but you could also have
inspiration at another level it was
widely believed that what happened in
dreams was not a a product of you know
what you ate or the problems you had
with your toilet training or something
of that sort but rather it came about
because the spirits appeared in your
dreams
if spirits appear in your dreams are
they telling you something
well the the practice of interpreting
dreams or divination by dreams is known
as Oni romancey and it was an extremely
widespread practice what we know about
it is mostly at the most important
political level so the ability of Joseph
to interpret dreams in the Bible or the
interpretation by who Daniel of the the
dream of Belshazzar the interpretation
of dreams shows up in these special
literary cases but interpretation of
dreams is also something that occurs
with almost everybody at least among
those people who remember their dreams
all those so I surprisingly many people
don't remember their dreams
I suspect that most people in this room
who remember their dreams try and
interpret them I certainly do
I have extremely vivid dreams great
whole you know badass movie scenarios of
dreams and you know and then afterwards
I try and figure out what it is and if I
wake up in the middle of the night I
think gee I'd like to see this now move
on to this and can pretty much go back
and resume the dream and get the story
going in another direction
and I'm very lucky in fact I have I just
I just couldn't do it
I've extremely detailed dreams and and
in fact I've recently come a conclusion
that when I die what I'm going to miss
most is dreaming because as you get
older and sicker
who wants really to continue the real
world but my hope is that the dreams
will remain cool and that that will be
worth missing anyway that's no point how
these thoughts mortality it was because
I'm retiring at the end of this year but
the interpretation of dreams is almost
unavoidable when it's your dream you
can't help to think about it and so you
have different theories about it that
arise one of the more interesting ones
is that in books on dream interpretation
written in the Muslim tradition one of
the fixed rules is that Satan can take
any form in a dream except the form of
the Prophet Muhammad so if Muhammad
appears to you in a dream it is Muhammad
if your brother-in-law appears that's
probably Satan but that's very important
because throughout the Muslim you know
religious tradition interpretation of
dreams plays an important role but it
played an important role for everybody
the Greeks believed in the the real
existence of spirits and dreams pretty
much everybody did because it was simply
a corollary of the broader belief in an
unseen world now in a more specific
fashion after all the dream is hard to
to conjure forth just because you want
it it happens or it doesn't happen but
you can't control it very much
however the the non dreaming corollary
of it
was that during your waking moments you
might be informed by a being from the
spirit world
happiness in ancient Greek Oh was the
word diamond AR o diamond AR l is good
and diamond is a spirit a lot of tension
with this word diamond because it's also
the word demon so that diamond can be
good or diamond can be bad or demon can
be bad and you have to look into the
tradition you're studying to see how
it's meant but for for the Greeks
happiness meant at its most primitive
level being informed or guided by a good
spirit the good spirit Oh
even though you don't necessarily
specify it as being an angel or
something else but it has your interest
at heart
it is benevolent it wishes the good for
you
the the Greeks also had a standard I
talking about more about the Greeks here
then about the Assyrians or the
Israelites because we know about this a
little bit more for the Greeks Lodge
because there's a very good book called
the Greeks and the irrational isn't
anyway I can't remember the author's
name right now I'll get somebody to look
that up but it gives all the details
about this sort of thing a poet
for the Greeks was regarded as being
inspired by a diamond and the the
ability to to create poetry was related
to what this diamond did within you
for the ancient Semites that you had the
same thing we know more about it for the
for Arabia Arabia before Islam actually
probably going back a very long way in
Arabia there was a category of unseen
being called the Jim this is what he's
extremely peculiar Arabic words that has
the plural is jam which is just
unspeakably unfair because it's not like
any other plural but the Jim were unseen
the spirits that lived in the desert
that were neither intrinsically
malevolent nor intrinsically benevolent
they were just there and they had you
know they did their own thing the Jim
had a a world to themselves but if a
jinn decided to do so he or she I
suppose could enter into a human and
become a source of inspiration and the
word
in Arabic is Majnoon it's a it means
literally ginned possessed by a gym now
in modern Arabic that is the word for
crazy a crazy person has a spirit in
them that is causing some sort of
dementia but in in ancient times someone
who is Majnoon could be described in
other ways so that Majnoon becomes the
the great paradigmatic lover a male
lover Majnoon is crazy mad in love and
it's one of the few articulations in the
ancient world of the idea of being crazy
mad in love which we think of primarily
as a television theme but it also was
used for poets just as the Greeks
believed that a poet was inspired by a
diamond or in a more literal literal
sense by a category of a diamond known
as the muses because the muses are
simply named diamonds you know they'll
speak o muses that sort of thing so in
Arabic in ancient Arabia a someone who
is a poet was thought it was being
possessed by a by a Jim as being Majnoon
this was
was not trivial if you if you learn
Arabic and you look into pre-islamic
Arabic poetry I would say the poetry
that goes back in time long before the
Prophet Muhammad you'll find that the
definition of a poem is that it is in a
certain meter and there are what 15 of
these meters and none of them are easy
to perceive none of this Dada Dada Dada
or Dada Dada da Dada Dada
if Japan came in thick draw even lamb
and zili you know there's a meter but
just try and extract something from it
because it's that it's not an intuitive
meter so if you lived in a community and
suddenly someone in your community can
do this you said why is why is Abid able
to do this and the rest of us can't
because because there he has a gin in
him and we should be proud of the fact
that someone from our community has this
indwelling spirit so the poet became the
the most important person in the in the
community because the poet could do this
now we have gotten away from the notion
of oral poetry very much and therefore
the idea that someone can just
spontaneously do this was let us say as
of 1980 clearly something nobody
believed in then rap came along and it
turned out some people can do it and not
your roommate and you wish you'd stop
trying
because it's just awful unbearable but
but there's some guy or some woman who
can who can do it and we don't say that
they're possessed by a by a diamond or a
gym but we don't call them crazy either
because they make much too much money we
just say it's kind of a gift but you
know the thing about a gift is that it
implies a giver and we are totally
agnostic on the question of giver where
does that gift come from
whereas in ancient times when you
believed in an unseen world you had no
trouble identifying the giver the giver
was something from from the unseen world
now there's another category that has to
do with prophets people who are are not
poets they're not dream interpreters but
they have a website but they are able to
convince the people around them that
they have had a revelation or a vision
that comes from the unseen world and in
the case of monotheism comes from the
high end of the unseen world but
prophecy does not have to be associated
with a single with a single God and
indeed
there are traditions particularly in
China where the notion of communicating
with the spirits that guide the world
focuses on the spirits of the ancestors
not on a god or a pantheon but simply on
the ruler or the head of the clan being
able to be in touch with the ancestors
so but but this is a notion of
inspiration now
inspiration is the least technological
of these of these things the technology
with poetry or something like that has
to do with the the way it's manifested
you a specific thing that the unseen
being teaches the technology of
sacrifice is is fairly self-evident you
take plant or animal matter and you you
know kill it or display it or drip it or
whatever on an altar and that is the
sacrificial act to leave its company buy
a lot of chanting if it's divination by
crack tortoise shells or by flight of
birds or by sheet slivers it's very
clearly a technology but but inspiration
that's that's tougher to to see as a
technology you can if you isolate it to
certain very certain institutionalized
beings like Oracle's or Sybil's who live
in certain places and who sniff glue or
whatever it was that caused the Delphic
Oracle people say was methane or some
other you know who loose inventory gas
leaking out of the rocks under Delphi
but the thing is the symbols and
Oracle's were specific beings that lived
in in specific places and had a kind of
technology but the notion of a prophecy
at large where you could simply
experience this notion of the divine
this becomes related tradition
particularly associated although not
really properly so with the biblical
tradition as it extends into
Christianity as extends into Islam but
you have lots of other
inspiration traditions the closest you
get to a technology of inspiration is
probably with meditation where you say
if you meditate whether you do it as a
Buddhist or do it as a Hindu or do it as
a Christian or whatever that you can
induce through the technology of
meditation a state of receptiveness in
which you could have inspiration it just
doesn't happen to you but you could for
Buddhism this is enlightenment so that
the inspiration is the sudden you know
sudden sense of enlightenment and
mystics for in all sorts of traditions
will have technologies of meditation or
mortification of the flesh or something
like that in order to to achieve a state
in which inspiration could appear but
you have a parallel notion that
institution that inspiration can be
random let's say in a Quaker meeting you
sit around and wait for the Holy Spirit
to descend upon someone but that's up to
the Holy Spirit it isn't something that
you come and you can coerce all right
these are technologies and associated
sciences that depend upon the
presumption that there is an unseen an
unseen world they have their analogues
for modern times when people no longer
think of an unseen world or more
properly they think of an unseen world
being the world of particle physicists
whoo-hoo we trust to be reliable
truth-telling witch doctors now there is
a argument that is made that in the
period from 800 to 200 BCE there is a
shift in this in this way of looking of
the world let me say it's long about BCE
BCE is obviously BC in the older
terminology it's configured as before
Christ extra or something like that but
that isn't really that's not getting
very far if CEO first the Common Era BC
evenings before the Common Era
it is a usage that began primarily with
Jewish scholars who really didn't like
the idea that you know the year of the
Lord or before Christ should be what
determines the calendar they use in
their books but it spread pretty widely
through through the same tendencies
toward world history and globalization
that give rise to a course like this
where lots of people who are not
interested in the year of the Lord or
the the birth of Jesus which we don't
know anyway are more comfortable with
BCE and and NCE for the Common Era
so that's what I use in this course the
the idea of there being a change that
takes place usually identified as a
change throughout the the cumin a a
Greek word meaning the known world that
is to say Middle East northern Africa
Europe Asia but not sub-saharan Africa
not the Western Hemisphere not Southeast
Asia of the notion of this this change
taking place in the Akuma nee between
eight hundred and two hundred b.c.e was
expressed initially by a German
philosopher named Karl Yas Paris and he
called that period
the axial age because he said that is
when the world pivots not when China
pivots or Egypt pivots but when the
world pivots around an axis and his
primary observation was that it's in
this period from 800 to 200 BCE that
Buddha Confucius Buddha in India
Confucius and louts of the
semi-legendary founder of Taoism in
China the major prophets in Israel
Isaiah Jeremiah and so forth and Xaro
Esther or Zarathustra and the Iranian
tradition they all lived in this period
now you you enter why it'll be an
obvious to any historian well before Yas
bears that these people lived roughly at
the same time and in if you can call a
six hundred year span the same time this
is like saying we have an axial age that
goes from you know you know four hundred
to two thousand because a lot of people
lived at the same time and oddly enough
you now have some people say we are in a
second axial age because we have Newton
and we have Freud and we have it you
think can you just do that can you just
lump everybody together and say the
world changes no you can't but that is
what gossipers was proposing of course
as you the farther back you look the
more truncated time becomes but six
centuries in a long period of time and
we're even skeptical about some of the
dates of people like Zahra Zoroaster or
Zarathustra probably lived before
800 BCE
you know certainly a strong Scalia
debate that would push his dates back
before that so why did yeah Spurs who as
a philosopher is thought of as an
existentialist why did why did this
catch on so that today you have world
historians who will talk about it but
even more you'll have religious studies
people who will expand on the nature of
the axial age Karen Armstrong for
example who's well known for her views
on religious matters what was it that
was so interesting about this did the
world really change well their device
looking at this you can say when did
blended Yas Affairs have his idea when
did when was the book published that had
this idea because no other idea of Yas
purrs really caught on his
existentialist theology is kind of murky
he had an influence on Heidegger but you
know influencing Heidegger no longer
impresses people very much since he was
influenced by the Nazis as well but the
osburgh's publishes this in 1949 you
think Oh big time thinker from Germany
publishes a book in 1949 why is anyone
paying any attention to what a German
says in 1949 when we've just got through
world war two well of course it turns
out that Yossef er is wrote a book just
before this that he published in 1946 a
book on the guilt of Germany in which he
said the guilt of Germany is in certain
certain categories that there's
obviously a guilt for having
a decision maker in the Nazi government
or this that and the other thing but
ultimately it is and is broadest level
he says there is a moral guilt that is
upon all Germans who chose to live
through this Nazi era and not lose their
lives trying to overthrow Hitler so here
you had a German he had been a professor
in Heidelberg of both psychology and
philosophy he left his post in 1935 but
did not leave Germany and he sat out the
entire Nazi era with a record that was
unbeaten with the Nazi regime and now at
the end of the war he's saying we are
all guilty well that that's kind of puts
him makes him German number one from an
American or allied standpoint you have a
really important German thinker who is
saying that there is a broad moral guilt
and who is also saying here is the
nature of the world and how the world
has evolved his idea was picked up even
though it's not a particular sunny idea
and you think okay now we can perhaps
understand apply apply oscar's was
intellectually acceptable but what what
about the idea well at the end of World
War two
particularly in the United States
although perhaps more broadly the idea
became current that the world could be
understood in its totality now before
them there had been very few American
thinkers who had tried something like
this you had had Oswald Spengler and
Germany who divided the world into
civilizations Arnold Toynbee in Britain
who divided the world into civilizations
those people who tried to look at the
world in its entirety deconstructed it
into into pieces but now here you have
Karly Oscars who's saying the difference
between China and Judaism and India and
Greece really is not that important
because they're all doing the same thing
at the same time it has been it appears
that Yass pers was very strongly
influenced by the German sociologist Max
Weber who had written books on ancient
China ancient India ancient Judaism and
on the relationship between
Protestantism and Catholicism along with
numerous other influential works that
were less specific by culture and so
what yaws pers is doing is saying well
you don't have to divide things up you
can look at the world as a whole now
what I'm saying is that in the aftermath
of World War two the notion of looking
at the world as a whole was very
attractive in the United States and
indeed it is what gives rise to
the notion of area studies the notion of
a broad approach to the entire
development of the world
so an approach that we generally call
modernization theory people who who were
part of the successful conquest of the
fascist regimes of the world some of
them not all of them but some of them
seem to have felt that they had a vision
of the whole thing that arose from the
sort of
uplifting experience that they had had
in America there was a strong view that
in the future the world's problems would
be solved by Americans we still have
that you know now we use a phrase
policemen of the world we didn't use the
phrase then but but the idea that the
United States would could solve the
world's problem problems had a corollary
in the academic intellectual arena which
said let us try to understand the world
as a whole rather than bit by bit and it
was very one of the means it's a very
specifically American thing is that the
European traditions that comes out of
intellectually where traditions that
were skewed by colonialism so that a
French person wouldn't think so much
let's think of the world as a whole
let's think about you know France and
Indochina and Algeria West Africa and a
Brit would think about let's think about
India and blah blah blah you would you
didn't see the world as a whole because
for the previous hundred two hundred and
fifty years Europe had been busy
dividing the world up and taking
possession of it piece by piece
the Americans either didn't have the wit
to do this or got left out or tried and
failed or we want to interpret the
history of American Pro to imperialism
going back to time William McKinley and
to some would be earlier but now the
Americans were saying the empires are
not the defining part of the world we
should think of the world as a whole
and we should think of
how does the world evolve as a whole the
the works that came out of this ranged
from highly influential particularly in
the area of modernization theory so that
a book by Walt Whitman Rostow called the
stages of economic growth was probably
the single book that was most most
highly touted and most read of when I
was undergraduate in the 60s the late
50s now you were a little bit later must
been graduate school because it
explained how the whole world was going
to to develop in the same direction
taking an economist approach when I was
an undergraduate I devoted a whole
semester to inventing a board game about
the development of the entire world that
was so complex that it was played once
we only got through two years and then
everyone said well you know screw this
and that that was the end of my
semesters work but but it was a
temptation how does the world work as a
whole people had different theories they
were not all economy economists ik
Manfred Halpern at Princeton felt that
he had discovered the seven
relationships that governed all human
interaction everywhere in the world for
all time and that every society could be
could be described fully by by the icons
that he associated with each of these
relationships so they say okay well that
society gets a smiley face and Anchor
they you know in an arrow or something
like that and that describes a society
of he or maybe two arrows interaction
according each other
I think Halperin was certifiably nuts
but and nobody really paid any attention
to his theory but the temptation was
there for grand theorization and yah
Spurs came along and wrote a book that
that really fit into this the mood of
the times that said the world is a hole
and the world changes as a whole even if
you cannot pin down the the interactions
between the parts of the world that are
changing they're they're changing in the
same direction
of course you could go back to Hegel and
say this is simply another version of
his notion of world historical feeling
except that Hegel believed that it was
episodic and happened in some areas not
others whereas the new idea was that the
world as a whole could change so people
were attracting the notion of an axial
age still are in some cases
and it might not be a bad idea I think
it's it is worth exploring whether there
was some sort of broad change if there
was could you characterize it and I
don't know whether how broadly it would
be but if there was the only thing I
that I can think of that might fit is
the decline of sacrifice the decline of
divining and the rise of inspiration or
inspiration / meditation / you know
cutting off your testicles and living a
celibate life in honor of God whatever
but the old views of the unseen world
that were related to technology and to
the the scientific or the scientistic
link between the technology of the
unseen world in the day to day and the
notion of a macrocosm that encompassed
the entire world those tendencies seemed
to recede
so that sacrifice becomes more and more
pro-forma without people really really
believing in it
divining gradually loses its its
credibility you might still have people
who who who talk about the the flight of
birds or omens of one sort or another
and indeed we down to this day people
who will sometimes think of omens which
is a type of of divinatory thinking but
by and large divining sub-field moves to
the to the margins and sacrifice move to
the margins or becomes bureaucratized
and an inspiration and and whether
sudden and involuntary or whether
induced by meditation or some other
technique becomes more important
Oh
to some degree this is you could say
this is a decline of science because you
don't have a very clear scientistic
theory to undergird inspiration
inspiration simply occurs or you hope it
occurs or something of that sort so I
think you do have a transition away from
a scientistic universe that was not real
science but have you know was thought of
by people as being real science toward a
much more fluid one and this coincides
with political changes that tend to move
away from the Association of individual
groups whether cities or tribes or
regional groups of villages something
association with a single with a
particular God that is the guardian of
the group two more generalized notions
of what sort of being in the unseen
world is involved
so one direction is a direction toward
prophecy and toward inspiration and for
European history this culminates really
in in early Christianity where the
writings of st. Paul make it clear that
Christians were supposed to be visited
by the Holy Spirit and being visited by
the Holy Spirit would enable them to
handle snakes without being bitten would
enable them to speak in tongues or to
understand the language of people who
spoke in tongues then and so forth and
so on
and it would enable people to heal
disease and to perform miracles miracles
become more numerous as a conceptual
category in the scientistic era where
you have the notion of a macrocosm and
microcosm miracles don't fit all that
well but when you move into something
that is more dependent upon prophecy and
an inspiration the sign of your
inspiration might be the capacity to
perform miracles certainly you know any
inspired person worth his salt in the
late ancient world could perform
miracles and did before miracles
according to the books written about
them at the time
you simply ascribed miracles and of
course down the present day if you're
going to be canonized you have to be
able to perform miracles or at least
your corpse has to be able to perform
miracles
so that's one direction and as I say
it's a it's a non-scientist ik one
another direction that I mention is the
numerological where you preserve a
certain scientistic element but you
become increasingly arcane in terms of
the inability of most people to to
follow numerology numerological
calculations so it's not wildly
important but another one that arises
that is more important is the rise of
the notion of fate or chance now you go
back to the ancient the early ancient
world a very little indication of people
thinking in terms of chance events now
fate was a little bit different because
you could say there is a certain
timeline that is laid out and that at
your posts the fate who cuts the
timeline and brings about your death at
the end of it you know as soon as you
are born that timeline is established
and fate will bring it to an end at a
given point and that fit pretty well
with the macrocosm microcosm idea and
everyone had a certain trajectory and
they might try to identify that
trajectory through the use of horoscopes
or some other idibon Ettore means and
you have the notion that you cannot
escape your fate although people will
try to escape their fate so forth and so
on but chance with something else
with the Greeks called a TK fortune
chance was based on the idea of
randomness that something's going to
happen to somebody it might as well
happen to me or if it's bad the module
happened to to Nathan
it's hot you know not me whatever you
just don't have very much in the in the
period that yah spares fans would
identify as pre Axial Age that relates
to fortune and you have a lot later on
you know fortune
could lead you to to take risks because
it might work
we're not up to Roman history yet but
Julius Caesar when he crossed the
Rubicon to invade Italy from Gaul is
said by futhark to have said in Greek
the die is cast
meaning the dice has been thrown and
what that meant was that he was taking a
chance and now the chance has been taken
and Caesar was famous in his in the
books about him for being the first one
into every battle you know you're gonna
have a sea battle you got off the ships
to invade the shore Julius was there
first even though he was the commander
because he said why you take a chance
and then one day he got unlucky and
everybody killed him but you know the
idea of chance was you know gradually
became more widespread and it was
terribly destructive of the notion of
the unseen world because chance appeared
to be non-directed fate was directed
chance seemed to be non directed
now I'm not sure whether this is enough
to identify an axial age or not it may
be that once you go back and look at the
specifics of Gaspar's approach and say
is there something that that is similar
in the in the teachings of Isaiah or
Jeremiah to the teachings of the Buddha
to the teachings of Confucius and lotsa
and first thing I don't see what that
would be but I'm a shallow technologist
so I don't have to see spiritual things
but I think that that there does appear
to be some sort of dying out or at least
loss of credibility for the unseen world
and the scientistic macrocosm microcosm
interpretation of it and in a sense the
person who most most reflects this dying
out or diminishment of influence yep I
mean you could talk about Greek
philosophers you know Plato and
Aristotle and so forth of the six people
who read their books but but I'm talking
about a more popular level there was a
Greek
a Greek philosopher named you himuro's
who lived in the fourth century BC or
third I don't remember exactly and he
you know think of this enjoy when you
when you reflect on Hesiod and the where
the gods come from you humorous said the
gods are originated as humans they are
simply men who lived at one time and did
certain things and and then people
talked about them and exaggerated the
things they did the longer they talked
about them the more the exaggeration
until finally they came to be regarded
as as gods
my wife told me about a famous
intellectual in India who had died you
know not so many years ago
and she asked a friend is he still
remembered and revered and the friend
said yes they're drawing pictures of him
now with four arms because he's now you
know
on his way to being God well you lemurs
said you had all these people who were
once kings or Chiefs and people told
stories about them and the stories got
exaggerated and so then they they said
well these these were gods and that's a
very very believable theory because when
we look at stories of saints and certain
other sort of larger-than-life people we
see the accumulation of stories over
time where they become grander and
grander and able to do miracles and so
forth but for you humorous and the
people who followed his views the
purpose was to to sort of kick the props
out from under the notion of the unseen
world being populated by gods oh the
gods were not it happens to the unseen
world they were just you know one-time
kings and so you don't have to pay much
attention to them the corollary to this
developed that if you were a king and
there was a theory that a great king
could become after the passage of so
many centuries a god then why don't you
just cut out the middleman and declare
yourself a god you're going to be a god
eventually you might as well enjoy it
while you're alive instead of waiting
five hundred years before people declare
your God so what you have at the end of
the ancient world that is say Oh
beginning around the fourth century BC
well within the BCE well within the
period of the axial age is that you have
rulers who
who declare themselves to be gods
sometimes by saying that they're
descendants of gods and having a
genealogical argument but sometimes just
flat-out saying they're their gods and
demanding that people worship them know
I am a god therefore let us build a
temple to me and all of you go to the
temple and sacrifice and pray to me
because I'm a god
now this is very close of course to
modern politics in America it's not
quite institutionalized in the same way
but it's a it's a symptom of the not of
the disappearance of belief in the
unseen world but of its channeling into
other you know into specific areas and
away from other areas so the god channel
begins to close down the divining
channel begins to close down the
inspiration channel opens up more the
chance or random chance side opens up
more all these have to do with the
common human denominator of of dealing
with innate spiritual urges that humans
have in some cases it has to do with
trying to take the spiritual away from
the specialists from the tech from the
technologically gifted and bring it down
to the level of the of everyday so that
you too can can do it
no as mentions in the book you have in
China where wet oracle bones where the
king the Michonne period would would
divine by asking a question will it rain
tomorrow many of these were many the
ones we know were specifically about
weather so will it rain tomorrow then
he'd apply a hot poker to the turtle
shell and it would crack and it would be
there a yes or a no crack and then on
many of these there was a notation made
of the bone as to whether it rained the
next day so they could keep records
since it wasn't aia scientistic
inspiration they keep records as to
whether this king was pretty good at the
lining or whether he was sort of no
maybe he should be traded to another
team or something like that but the
oracle bones only last for a couple of
hundred years and what replaces them
euro stocks
the yarrow is a plant it has stalks the
stalks are lightweight you can take the
arrow plant and strip it of its leaves
and now you have Garrow stalks and you
can divide your handful of yarrow stalks
into piles in a certain fashion and once
you've done a certain number of
divisions according to a certain
technology a certain pattern you will
end up with a with 1212 trigrams in a
matrix and you can then look up the
meaning of them in the in the Book of
Changes 3ej
well the arrow stocks don't require an
emperor
anybody can divine in this fashion so
here's a case where it is the technology
changes and allows the the contact with
the unseen world to become localized
down to the level of the individual
person seeking knowledge about the
future and you don't depend upon the
king so there there are a number of
different trends that that develop but
it certainly is arguable that by the
time you get to 200 BC or thereabouts
you're in a rather different spiritual
world everywhere in the old the old
world now say the Eurasian Okuma neigh
now this has not involved any discussion
of Greek philosophy if you were teaching
this as Western Civ you would say there
were changes and let's talk about Plato
and Aristotle because this is the road
that you follow teleologically to get to
where we are now in the story of Western
Civ but one of the virtues of Yas first
notion of an axial age is that while he
puts Plato and Aristotle in there he
doesn't give them such a important
position that they become the whole the
story so next week I'll talk about Iran
and Greece and I have asked you to read
an article I wrote and a couple of
excerpts from a terrible book that I
don't recommend that anybody read by a
UCLA historian named
Hagman and what's interesting in it in a
sense is that it's the absolute opposite
of the tendency after world war ii to
see the whole world Magda and others
like him now are trying to see the world
divided into permanently antagonistic
groups primarily the west and Islam so
we'll get that next week